oui david pierre karl péladeau qui a
sauté dans la mêlée depuis le
déclenchement premier point de presse et
bien sûr ils s'attaquent au npd le bloc
aimerait ravir ces électeurs-là qui
avaient voté npd la dernière lorsque sur
le terrain il ya une inquiétude là les
militants organisateurs bloquiste
constate que des électeurs qui seraient
normalement souverainiste veulent voter
disent vouloir voter pour le npd
simplement pour battre stephen harper
donc aujourd'hui les deux leaders
indépendantistes ont tiré à boulets
rouges sur le chef néo-démocrate
monsieur duceppe a parlé d'un
centralisateur de nos adversaires de la
loi 101 et comme pierre karl péladeau et
l'a voulu peut-être un peu de défaire
l'image d'environnementalistes de faire
mouche bancaire en critiquant tous les
deux la décision de musulmans au caire
d'appuyer le projet de pipeline de
transcanada on les écoute monsieur
duceppe et monsieur péladeau
monsieur le monde perd pas son temps à
dire que c'est un gros projet en avril a
dit khin win win win
ces candidats au québec zecs c'est un
non non le cadre on vérifie ou une win
win non non non c'est pas mal traduction
les néo démocrates et le parti
conservateur ont le vieux encore
aujourd'hui avec la position de monsieur
mulcair sur l'oléoduc
ça commence à ressembler bonnet blanc
blanc bonnet et on a posé la question
pierre karl péladeau mais sa position
sur les pipelines nuit au québec il
était pour ce projet à une époque là il
a adopté la position du parti les
comptes
et puis écoutez c'est que le sujet est
délicat au parti québécois le pétrole
disons que les péquistes ne sont pas
tous sur la même longueur d'onde de là
dessus se fait là d'où s'étaient
embourbées sur cette question là au mois
de juin aujourd'hui questionné à savoir
s'il se poserait à tout projet de
pipeline transportant du pétrole issu
des sables bitumineux
il a refusé de répondre prétextant que
ce n'était pas la bonne tribune
on écoute le chef péquiste
on peut pas aborder dans un point de
presse des questions aussi importantes
que les hydrocarbures
je peux pas je suis désolé mais je peux
pas vous donner une réponse qui vont
être un clip de 30 secondes sur des
questions aussi fondamentales que les
énergies au québec prises pour conclure
la campagne fédérale mais on verra
beaucoup ce chef provincial du parti
québécois parce que pierre karl péladeau
ce qu'on entend entre les branches c'est
qu'à son avis ça pour être un bon
endroit pour mettre en relief les
défauts disons du système fédéral donc
on entendra monsieur péladeau
abondamment humour de cette campagne et
il a fait un appel quelques secondes
david il a fait un appel au premier
ministre pour qu'il s'implique dans la
campagne ce que monsieur couillard ne
fait pas jusqu'ici il ne l'a pas fait
jusqu'ici il le fera en fin de semaine
lors de ce congrès des jeunes libéraux
où il présentera ses demandes sa liste
d'épicerie aux chefs des différentes
formations fédérales
mais voilà c'est clair merci des bonnes
soirées